siamo finalmente arrivati a questo video
ragazzi d'oggi ragazzi sia la prossima
domenica ci sarà un episodio speciale la
prossima domenica signori farò un
episodio di cinque ore di più
segnatevelo ragazzi domenica 30 agosto
il pomeriggio dalle 15 alle 20 ci
saranno cinque ore di happy meals sarà
una cosa incredibile
non vedo l'ora di farlo in alta per il
centesimo episodio ho fatto speciale
un'ora adesso faremo 5 sarà assurdo
comunque ragazzi per il 199 semi episodi
volevo fare un altro speciale siamo qua
oggi a fare una sorta di tuffo nel
passato una reaction ai miei primissimi
episodi anche perché quando ho iniziato
le prime sei stato quando ho aperto il
canale quindi erano i primissimi video
ok quindi si vedeva e fa vj quello che
aveva appena aperto il canale con la
marmotta morta che urlava cacchio ci
sarà un cazzo un [ __ ] una merda ogni
cinque secondi quindi sticazzi di tanto
sto video né femmini prendi non può
esserlo scusatemi aumentato il prelievo
cup orario con nel tempo però all'inizio
era tutto in una roba così come iniziale
episodio 1 volevo proprio vedere
l'approccio iniziale di happy meals 3
febbraio 2013 questo è il primo let's go
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fuori j
e oggi siamo nel primissimo episodio di
happy days molto meno klinge di quanto
pensassi avevo già fatto l'upgrade della
webcam perché ai tempi usavo un l'ha
votata nelle nei cereali una cosa che
riprendeva orribile equa era già quella
un po meglio quindi non male anche
l'audio ragazzi ci ho messo un audio una
merda vediamo il primo livello che ho
fatto a caso d'odio non avendo mai
provato a registrare nulla su happy
wings non so che cosa può uscire fuori
dalla pagina un bordello sì quello che
posso dire io niente per questo weekend
solo per questo weekend
mica durerà nei prossimi otto anni no ma
vabbè ci facevo sempre così con le mani
che non è notato che ho fatto questo
gesto
guardate senza audio e guardate quante
volte faccio questo gesto senza un
motivo
ma basta press z by il primo livello di
e primis ragazzi è stato non lo faccio
questa roba ci mette un po però alla
fine capisco prendi bravo bene lascio
lascio questa non è la primissima volta
che ho giocato ad happy meals perché era
già conosciuto è poi se noi lo giocavamo
nel laboratorio di informatica della
scuola cioè noi avevamo una chiavetta
dove dentro avevamo un browser che era
mozilla andavamo nel computer della
scuola africa ma la chiavetta aprivamo
mozilla hit come zyl andiamo sul sito di
mtv se giochiamo a de pedis quindi non
ero non era proprio la prima volta che
giocava dai più vi era la prima volta
commentata che commentare un gioco è
comunque più difficile rispetto a
giocarci e basta comunque molto carino
dei capelli zio complimenti a questa
prima vittoria
bene cos'è cos'è cos'è cos'è perché
parlavo cos'è perché va bene ok
mamma mia ma bella secondo tentativo
ragala gambe altrimenti tutti
appendiabiti ragazze non ci arriva il
coltello sono cadendo tutti stanno
cadendo da tra avevo i capelli che mi
finivano qua ed era bruttissimo perché
mi faceva un progretto pazze orribile
sta arrivando
oddio no non posso difendermi non va ok
bene mia mi ha schiacciato perfetto
comunque ragazzi molto più bravo di
quanto vi ricordarsi perché comunque
erano i primissimi video è c'è senso qua
dovevo imparare ancora fare lo youtuber
a farci duca devo riuscire a far
canestro che devo riuscirci
assolutamente comunque si no si spera
insomma che io ci sia riuscito però va
bene c'è praticamente io rispetto a un
tempo la cosa che ho cambiato è stato il
evitare di parlare così che la vera fine
non è necessario credo se non quando mi
cadde addosso i capelli aveva tolto
anche un po di parolacce ma in generale
è la società credo di essere molto
migliori sono a parte gli scherzi cioè
dai 9 c'è stato un miglioramento
pazzesco soprattutto nei capelli
se volete farlo ancora cos'è però non
capisco il senso è se ok la segnalate
due ore dopo ci sta bravo dell'editing
vero regalo la scopa di harry potter
posso sentire il king che parte da qua
dalla punta del pitato notate le mie
calze bellissima dalla punta del piede
mi arriva qua dove una volta risiedeva
la marmotta ma ragazzi basta vuoi stare
su questo video andiamo sul prossimo
perché comunque ci hanno fatto fatti
altri ovviamente questi titoli non li
potrei mai più utilizzare nella youtube
di oggi però li teniamo perché ormai è
così a spezzarmi notiamo i primissimi
commenti che sono grazie mille
ma cosa il pogo fatto effettivamente non
saprei parla neanche adesso questo sì ho
capito però stai calmo queste quasi
peggio di quello dell'altra volta
effettivamente sì vabbè steve ti sei
ripreso per prima lo sa per prova a dire
la stessa frase va beh sì 26 il prezzo
per prima e non riescono al khalifa non
riesco a rifare la mia voce ed è
impossibile epoche come parlavo strano
che scrivete noi ci vediamo al prossimo
video bella ragazza ragazzi aqua poi
c'era la prova del video precedente che
al televisore o televisione era
bruttissimo che ruotava su se stesso
tensione e poi si fissava nel mezzo e
compariva il video precedente sta cosa
molto [ __ ] anche sui motori
tanta roba ma si vedeva che utilizzavo
la webcam quella ancora prima cosa che
faceva schifo siete proprio la qualità
già anche da qua era orribile ma ragazzi
oggi e domenica 26 luglio sta resistendo
questo video molto prima perché mi devo
preparare per il 200esimo episodio che
voglio vedere andando al 26 luglio 2013
quindi esattamente sette anni fa come
ero conciato andiamo direttamente
l'episodio del 26 luglio ragazzi 21 a no
perché avevo fatto è l'avevo fatto su
motori mi sa che ho fatto sui motori a
26 luglio per una volta lo alternava su
motori dreams quindi mi sa che il 26
luglio è uscito su motori dreams così
sicuramente comunque più o meno quello
più vicino a un anno fa e questo si vede
proprio dalle vene del collo si vede dal
direi iniziare subito
facciamo walking match ai ragazzi non so
che riveli sto facendo non lo so siamo
che o addio
ok abbiamo iniziato un po di kring
quindi forse meglio se questi non li
guardiamo se ci facciamo forza possiamo
guardarli
ma bisogna resistere a denti stretti ma
proviamoci anche in un transformer è
questo non me lo aveva detto
cos'è auto worker presso space star mi
fa male il cuore problema spiega
l'attuale dove erano ragazzi non ce la
faccio scusate è come quando vengono dei
vostri amici a casa e la vostra mamma mi
fa vedere delle foto di con travate
piccoli è la stessa cosa forse peggio
arriviamo così al 20 qualcosa luglio
vuoi vedere quello di un anno fa preciso
eccolo qua qua mi ero appena svegliato
ragazzi vede dall'occhio che più chiuso
guardavate aspetta quando io c'ho eccolo
eccolo a quando ciò scoppio più chiuso
qua io perché mi sono appena svegliato e
ho sempre avuto sto problema poi pian
piano in realtà è da un po che non mi
viene mandato via poi non so se mi
ritornerà sempre la stessa maglia anche
qua non l'ho mai lavata dopo tutto
questo tempo fresco ragazzi era un anno
preciso dopo aver scalato tutta la vetta
di happy with del mondo perché non so
chi ha fatto così tanti episodi come me
siamo arrivati all'episodio
questo sono molto molto orgoglioso del
fatto di essere riusciti a portare più
di per così tanto tempo perché il gioco
sul mio canale che in tutti questi anni
non è mai morto è stato una costante e
oggi siamo qua io vi ringrazio ringrazio
per avermi accompagnato in questa
avventura pazzesca se ci pensate perché
da quando io ero così non mi sarei mai
mai mai lo dico sempre aspettato di
arrivare di arrivare ad alzare il
microfono perché quest'anno il microfono
già tutto il tempo vedere che un po una
merda adesso invece lo tengo su e molto
figo questo cambiamento
quindi ragazzi spero vi sia piaciuto
questo è il 199 vi ricordo che due città
i suoi milioni di acquisti sarà domenica
30 agosto saremo in live per cinque ore
di fila non vedo l'ora
ci deve essere tutti per i 200 episodi
poi sarà un traguardo pazzesco dopo
tutto questo che avete visto non potete
mancare ragazze di vara prossimo ragazzi
cose insieme più giorno meno mi piace
anche un risorsa come nota letizia le
sentono si rischia temi e noi come
sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo vivo
bella ragazza
[Musica]